más vino viene de vivir un verano de
ensueño ella junto con sus compañeros de
la selección francesa conquistaron el
oro olímpico en la modalidad por equipos
mixtos en judo lo hicieron ante la
poderosa delegación de japón los
anfitriones toda una proeza
ahora está judoca de 27 años asegura
vivir una pesadilla con esa foto en
redes sociales mago denunció haber sido
golpeada por su pareja y ex entrenador
alan smith pensé que me moría logré
escapar para refugiarme en casa de mis
vecinos que inmediatamente llamaron a la
policía
tengo muchas heridas entre ellas una
fractura en la nariz y diez días de baja
laboral esto ocurrió el sábado en el
domicilio de la pareja a las afueras de
parís según marco ella denunció a su
agresor el mismo fin de semana y este
martes un tribunal lo absolvió por falta
de pruebas este caso ha indignado al
mundo del judo incluyendo a estrellas
como la bicampeona olímpica clases acn
ven y no ya te dejan era considerado uno
de los más grandes a judokas de todos
los tiempos
todos estamos profundamente afectados
por lo que acaba de sufrir nuestra
compañera marco opinó le brindamos todo
nuestro apoyo que hace falta para que
las víctimas sean escuchadas que los
agresores sean hallados culpables alan
smith niega la agresión y asegura que
todo fue fruto de una discusión que
subió de tono y por la que ambos
terminaron agrediéndose según smith su
pareja estaba disgustada porque él iba a
partir de israel a entrenar a su
selección femenina de judo o una
situación así es la justicia ellos
tienen el derecho de hacerlo y lo
hicieron ahora por el contrario lo que
no respeto es el linchamiento mediático
que se hizo alrededor de esto instagram
twitter son todo excepto un tribunal la
federación de ayuda de israel suspendió
cualquier contacto con alan después de
esta denuncia por su parte la fiscalía
que había solicitado un año de prisión
condicional presentó una apelación